doing some home improvement but hoping
to avoid a trip to urgent care well
these apps can help you with simple DIY
tasks safety home depot's app does more
than just promote its products the app
has enough T toolbox with different
measuring tools and converters it can
also calculate how much drywall paint
carpet or installation you'll need for
your project you plug in the dimensions
of the room and the app tells you how
many cans of paint you need to buy I
handy carpenter will make sure those
shelves you're putting up are in fact
straight it has a plan Bob surface level
bubble level steel protractor and ruler
all-in-one see the perfect pink color at
a branch spot but don't know what it's
called bears color match up or match
anywho from a photo and locates a store
nearby that carries the paint next is
project color another app from the
people at Home Depot you take a photo of
the room you want to paint and try out
the different colors but if you're still
having trouble with that drill or can't
figure out how to properly assemble your
ikea furniture you can rent a human to
do it for you handy is kind of the uber
for home services tell them what you
need done and they'll come on over and
sort it out for you